to think of the 39 like toys that have
been
that's what they tell me yeah
[Music]
by triskin - gasps self - it would not
start with a question about your
legality no human being is illegal
this is a vendor's but it's kind of not
surprisingly because I think that this
this whole process now with migrants and
refugees in relation to coming into
Europe he's being repeated as a tragedy
almost every day I mean thousands of
people have now drowned in a
Mediterranean about it and I think that
the kind of fortress Europe and a
hostile environment that exists
politically for Markinson Fugees least
two tragedies like this at least people
in the arms of the traffickers that's
the only way they can move
[Music]
people that are in quite desperate
situations are clearly being forced into
incredibly dangerous situations which
are leading to the horrors that we saw
in the last few days so partly we're
holding the vigil tonight
you know highlight that a sports stand
in solidarity with those affected
[Music]
you